CARTER MORGAN: Today,
it's time to figure out
how Kubernetes actually
runs containers on nodes.
Let's check it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With a whole universe
of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
So with all of our
conversation about how
pods run in our
containers, I figured
it would make sense
to talk about nodes,
which means it's time to
figure out, what are nodes?
KASLIN FIELDS: That's
an important topic.
The simple way of
looking at it is
that a node is a virtual
or physical machine
that you run your workloads on.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow.
That's pretty straightforward.
And I know that
in Kubernetes, we
operate on clusters, which are
groups of one or more worker
nodes.
But in order to get the
automation that Kubernetes
provides, I'm sure
nodes are more than just
any old virtual or
physical machine, right?
KASLIN FIELDS: Exactly.
Each node actually contains the
services necessary to run pods.
A container runtime
for running containers,
a kubelet for making
sure that everything that
should be running is,
and the kube-proxy
for handling networking.
CARTER MORGAN: Ah-ha.
So that's how Kubernetes
keeps track of pods.
That also explains how
pods get IP endpoints
and other necessary features
for running at scale,
like being able to attach to
a running pod for debugging.
KASLIN FIELDS: Yep.
Now, if we had to
manually manage
all of the pods on each node, it
would be impossible to handle.
That's one of the most important
reasons Kubernetes exists.
The way Kubernetes
actually manages
these pods is through what's
called the control plane.
CARTER MORGAN: The
control plane is
responsible for handling
all of these details
by exposing an API.
This is where Kubernetes can
define, deploy, and manage
the lifecycle of our pods.
KASLIN FIELDS: Right.
There's a lot going on
in the control plane.
Let's look at some
of the components
that make up the control
plane and what they do.
First, there's the
API server itself,
which handles data validation
and configuration for all
of the API objects.
CARTER MORGAN:
Next, there's etcd,
which is a key-value
store for holding
onto all the important
data that Kubernetes uses.
Plus, there's the Scheduler.
Here's where the
important decisions
get made about where
exactly a pod will run.
The Scheduler can look at the
available resources for all
the nodes and make
sure that a pod goes
to a node that can handle it.
KASLIN FIELDS: And don't
forget about the Controller
Manager, where the core
Kubernetes logic happens.
One of the big responsibilities
here is lifecycle management,
to make sure all the various
pieces are working correctly.
Similarly, there is the
Cloud Controller Manager,
which lets Kubernetes
hook into cloud providers.
So if you're running
Google Kubernetes Engine,
the Cloud Controller Manager
is what speaks to Google Cloud
when something is needed, like a
new virtual machine for a node.
CARTER MORGAN: Having that
abstraction from dealing
with the individual details
of each cloud provider sure
sounds nice.
Wow.
The control plane is
responsible for a lot.
But with all of that, how do
you actually declare the details
to Kubernetes?
KASLIN FIELDS: That's where
the Kubernetes API comes in.
Let's try it out in
the next episode.
CARTER MORGAN: So that's how
Kubernetes does all the things
that it does.
If you're going to
deploy a container,
you'd make a pod that
uses your container,
you'd make sure
Kubernetes has nodes,
and then it figures
out the rest.
KASLIN FIELDS: That's right.
The kubelets on the
nodes are watching what's
going on on the node itself.
So when the control
plane needs to schedule
a pod on that node, both the
control plane and the node
itself have enough information
to make sure it works.
CARTER MORGAN: Plus, if
a pod runs into an issue,
the control plane will
work with the kubelet
to remove the unhealthy pod
and replace it with a new one.
Wow.
That was a lot of
great info on nodes.
But now, it's time to take a
deeper dive into the Kubernetes
API.
All right.
Stay tuned, everybody.
If you want to get
hands-on, check out
the link in the description.
And if you enjoyed the
episode, subscribe for more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]